very good thank you
I don't know what okay there's no
politics education is key because it
please do but the development of a child
and then he can think for himself
then he can be in more entrepreneurial
he can look for opportunities so
education is the key to development
growth and prospects and opportunities
for every temperature my personal vision
is to get Bangladesh is all Bangladesh
is poor get out of poverty we are trying
to extricate people out from poverty
from different angles not just improving
income and employment but also improving
their opportunities so that they can
have access to education access to
health care and access to a more
dignified life faizul Hasan Abed is a
visionary his Development Agency brac is
based in the capital Dhaka he studied
and worked abroad but moved back to
Bangladesh in 1971 to find a country
left in ruins by natural disaster and
the struggle for independence from
Pakistan
the devastation prompted him to sell his
apartment in London and change his life
completely
I used to be a business executive I used
to work for shale oil company and I left
shale didn't decided to do this and
initially of course I thought I'd do it
for a few years but then when we found
the poverty is so intense in Bangladesh
that we had to commit ourselves for the
whole life and not just few years
previous Pandu it used to be the second
poorest country in the world after
working up a soil there were a lot of
child mortality in one village quarter
of our children right before their fifth
birthday so we had to do something about
type mortality reduction reducing child
mortality rates in slums is one of his
top priorities the brac project focusing
on bettering maternal neonatal and child
mortality in urban areas is called mono
XI so we decided to go from house to
house teaching mothers how to make oral
rehydration fluid at home and how to
administer it it took us 10 years to go
to 13 million households in Bangladesh
and teach one to one one woman in every
household how to make all the addition
so that has a big impact in the country
in cutting down infant mortality from
the idea prax guiding principle is that
poverty amelioration can only be
sustained through greater equality in
gender roles
it therefore advocates women's rights
and the improvement of their welfare by
training midwives for example who look
after women too poor to afford a doctor
in intervention areas neonatal mortality
rates have subsequently declined as have
maternal mortality rates
thanks to brac 25 million women now
receive medical attention we work with
women allotted in this country
microfinance clients more than 6 million
clients are all women we want to the
women because women in Bangladesh has
been the managers of poverty they manage
poverty in the household so we thought
that if the managers of property are
women why not shouldn't they be the
managers of development that's what we
we focused our attention on women's
development and women's empowerment
every program that we did we first
started small made it effective and then
efficient and then scaled up throughout
the nation so so one secret is that most
NGOs remains small and beautiful they
don't want to grow very much but we were
very ambitious we wanted to change
Bangladesh and that's the reason why we
had to become large and effective rather
than small and beautiful brac is now the
world's largest NGO operating in 11
countries with a staff of 120,000 and an
annual budget of 500 million euros only
part of which comes from donations
the rest is generated by the
organization itself it's many subsidiary
companies investments and Bank I'm happy
that I've changed my life to another to
the direction in which I've come I would
have been otherwise a professional
person I would probably have retired by
the age of 65 62 I'm now 78 I am still
working in my organization and I find a
great deal of satisfaction and working
in this organization there are so many
more things to be done so I can't feel
satisfied that I have done everything
that I wanted to do
I still need to do many more things a
decision that will continue to help
those in need